انفجارات بالفعل كانت هذه اصواتا غير
مالوفه لنا قال لي كلمه واحده لقد بدات
انا فهمت كل شيء
[موسيقى]
لقد هجموا علينا حقا من جميع الجهات في
الصباح الباكر وكان اصعب شيء بالنسبه لي
هو كيف اقول للاطفال كان علي ان اذهب الى
الغرفه واوقظهم واخبرهم بان الحرب قد بدات
لكن لحسن الحظ لقد استيقظوا بالفعل وفهموا
بالفعل كل شيء
[موسيقى]
نفكر جميعا في شيء واحد فقط متى تنتهي
الحرب ومتى تبدا الحياه الطبيعيه لان هذا
العام لا يمكن ان يسمى حياه طبيعيه نحن
منفصلون يمكنني رؤيته عده مرات في الاسبوع
ونادرا ما يراه الاطفال للاسف
[موسيقى]
هل رسبتم اي محاولات اغتيال بالفتره
الماضيه لك وللاطفال
في الامر فسيكون من المخيف ان تعد احاول
ان لا افكر اكتشفت ذلك لاحقا انه كان هناك
محاوله مزعومه ومن الجيد انني اكتشفت ذلك
لاحقا لانني كنت خائفه
حتى الان مات اكثر من اربع مئه وخمسين
طفلا هذا رقم رهيب ما يقرب من ضعف هذا
العدد مصابون ومشوهون وبالفعل هناك مثل
هذه الجروح التي احدثتها الحرب والتي
ستعطي علامات بعد سنوات او حتى عقود هذه
اصابات نفسيه لا شيء يمكن مقارنته عندما
راى الطفل وفاه والديه بعينيه
[موسيقى]
لا يوجد
اشكركم مره اخرى على هذه المقابله للعالم
العربي انا حقا اريدك ان تسمعنا اعلم ان
لدينا قيم مشتركه وستفهموننا ستفهمون
مشاعرنا اننا ندافع عن انفسنا ونحمي
مستقبلنا وحياه اطفالنا هذه هي المشاعر
الوحيده التي توحد الاوكرانيين الان